[Music]
Sebastian if you had just seen it up
there the ship rode on the wind and they
filled the sky with fire okay okay
listen to me the human world is a mess
life under the sea is better than
anything they got going on up there this
Seafood is always greener if somebody
else's league
is a big mistake just look at the world
around you right here on the ocean floor
such wonderful things surround you what
more is you're looking for
[Music]
is better don't worry sweater take it
from me
up on the shore they work all day out in
the sun they slave away while we've
devoted full time to floating under the
sea
[Music]
the guardianship
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you broke the rules he went to the above
World a man was drowning I had to save
him this obsession with humans has to
stop I just want to know more about them
[Music]
I can help
another world unless you become a human
yourself is that even possible
that's what I live for
hahaha
[Music]
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
[Music]
someday I'll be
he's a Healer you're a mermaid that
doesn't make us enemies
[Music]